Speaker 1: You know, for a little while, it
was mostly a radical Republican Congresswoman,
Marjorie Taylor Green, who was comparing things
to the Holocaust, equating things to the Nazis,
raising other comparisons to World War Two.
It's now just becoming very widespread on
the American right, and it has a lot to do
with vaccines.
We're going to look at a few clips.
Here is David Brody, who used to be a regular
panelist on Meet the Press.
He was on his show, I guess he has a show
now, water cooler on real America's voice.
I don't know.
I don't even know what that means.
He is again talking about Nazis and Nuremberg
codes when it comes to vaccination.
Take a listen.
Speaker 2: Violation of federal law.
So why?
Well, because it would violate a little thing
called the Nuremberg Code Code mentioned on
the FDA website, not pizza, gay.com or conspiracy.
Donnette, the Nuremberg Code emphasizes that
people cannot be forced to take experimental
drugs without their full consent.
Now, interestingly, interestingly here, the
term Nuremberg Code originated in nineteen
forty seven Germany during the Nuremberg trials,
where, of course, Nazi doctors attempted to
excuse the inhumane, deadly experiments that
they conducted on concentration camp prisoners
by claiming that there were no explicit rules
governing medical research on human beings
in German.
During that period, but you're probably thinking,
well, hey, hold on, that's Nazi Germany and
Nuremberg Code or or not, the US government
would never admit.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so so the implication is
that having a requirement in order to work
at certain places or go to certain schools
or whatever the case may be, that that's equivalent
of a Phase three trial.
Widely, phase three trialed vaccine is similar
to Nazi medical experimentation on Jews.
Now, that sounds sort of crazy because it
is.
So then when he brings on his guest Mat Staver,
he sort of says, you know, we're not literally
saying that, but you kind of ardo take a listen.
Speaker 2: Well, you know, it's interesting.
You say the sirens should go off and you're
absolutely right.
Unfortunately, the sirens going off the other
way, the vaccinated or excuse me, the vaccine
in this country are being demonized, that
there's discriminatory stuff going on out
there.
I'm curious as it relates to the legal issues
here regarding the Nuremberg Code.
I mean, if it's under experimental use, what
does that mean legally in terms now even that
Speaker 1: when they say what e it just so
happens that experiment and emergency both
start with the letter E, an EU way is an emergency
use authorization.
It's not an experimental use authorization.
That's that's another deliberate deception
Speaker 2: of this going up the legal food
chain.
What could happen here?
Well, even before you get to the Nuremberg
Code, you have the emergency use authorization
law clearly says that you have the, quote,
option to accept or refuse, close quote.
That's repeated in the factsheet required
by the FDA.
And it's also mentioned many times by the
FDA.
So that's the end of story.
You have the option to refuse when it's an
U.S. and it's an EOA specifically designated
so by the FDA.
Speaker 1: Now, do you guys believe that when
you were somewhere between two and five weeks
from at least the Fizer vaccine given given
permanent approval by the FDA, do you think
that when that happens, they'll just say,
oh, now we're good, now go and get vaccinated?
Of course not.
They're just going to come up with something
else.
Speaker 2: And federal law in the Nuremberg
Code, the very first point says that the voluntary
consent of the human subject is absolutely
essential.
There should be no duress, no deception, no
pressure.
And we're doing exactly the opposite.
We are violating federal law.
We're violating the Nuremberg code.
All of these will be brought into court to
raise these issues because we are repeating
this is the tragic part of this.
We're repeating the dark history of Nazi Germany
and we're not learning the lessons that the
Nuremberg,
Speaker 1: you know, we're really not mat
Speaker 2: code.
And those Nazi experiments should have taught
this generation.
So you're likening it to that time period.
We talked about that in the monologue.
And we want to be clear, I guess we have to
do the disclaimer about the Holocaust.
We Jews, we're not talking about that.
Speaker 1: Right.
I begrudgingly have to mention we're not really
talking about the Holocaust, except we are,
because we're saying that a required vaccine
after phase three trials violates the Nuremberg
codes, just like the Nazis did during their
medical experiments.
It's crazy.
This is where there now is this is the plane
where they now exist.
Here's one more example.
Newsmax guest Pastor Brian Gibson.
Yeah.
Says that vaccinations are
Speaker 2: just won the election.
Speaker 1: That was actually an accident.
Newsmax guest Pastor Brian Gibson says vaccination
is going to provide a framework for future
genocide.
Yeah.
Speaker 2: What do you make of that, pastor?
Yeah, yeah, they're playing this comes straight
out of the Marxist handbook, right?
You try to set as many different groups against
each other as you can in a nation to weaken
it, tear it apart and rebuild it in the image
you want.
At first in America, it was it was racial
tension, black versus white.
Now we're moving from vaccinated to the unvaccinated.
And I'll tell you, it's scary because whenever
you see guys saying you see leaders saying
you can go to the gym if you have the vaccination,
you see the president talking about the problem,
that is the unvaccinated.
These things have played out before in history.
Speaker 1: He's sort of alluding to saying
the unvaccinated in a pejorative way is like
when the Nazis started saying the Jews, that
if you're not making the connection, this
is the analogy he's making.
And then he actually just straight up says,
Speaker 2: where do you take a certain group
of people and demonize them?
And I'll tell you what it is.
It's a framework for animosity between two
groups at best.
At worst, it's a framework for a future genocide.
Speaker 1: So there it is, just like the Jews
started to be demonized by the Nazis, the
unvaccinated are starting to be demonized
by the vaccinated, I guess, and by Joe Biden,
that we are in real, real serious trouble
here as a country.
My friends, if these narratives become the
prevailing narrative.
So once we get that FDA approval, let's see
how many of them go out and get vaccinated.
It won't be, quote, experimental anymore,
as they like to say.
Let's see how many of them go out and get
vaccinated at that point in time.
Let me know your thoughts on Twitter.
You can find me at Pakman and remember that
we are now just about ten days away from The
David Pakman Show 16th anniversary.
On that day, August 16th, you can get an insanely
discounted David Pakman show membership.
I would love for you to do that and support
the program if you want to be notified on
August 16th of how to do that, just get on
my newsletter at David Pakman dot com.